uh it's a pleasure to have mark rudelson
will tell us about lower estimates of
marginal density
thank you and i'd like to thank the
organizers
for inviting me i hope to be in berkeley
physically but
this is not possible and
i realized that this is the last talk of
the workshop this is
friday evening so i'll try to make it
shorter but i will see
this is a joint work with hermann koenig
from
the university of kiev and
this is the this is about the question
which
was asked some time ago
by statisticians
and this morning was
said that there are three main topics of
this workshop
low concavity concentration
and hypercube i'll try to check as many
boxes as possible there will be a lot of
log concavity
there will be some ideas from measure
concentration
there will be no hypercube but there is
there will be a substitute a discrete a
solid cube
so let's start
and i'll start with a
known theorem that if you have a vector
with
iad coordinates having bound density
regardless of the moments and you take
a marginal of this random vector
you project it on a subspace of
dimension d
and then the maximal density
of the marginal will be
bounded in terms of the maximal density
of the original
random coordinate
and the factor depending on d
and there was a question
whether we can derive a similar
lower estimate for the density
let's uh so the question let's make it
more concrete
the question i was asked was suppose
that we have
a density which is bounded below
on a symmetric interval
is it true that we can bound
the density of the marginal
if we evaluate it at the point whose
norm is less than the same
a
uh with the factor
independent of the ambient
dimension n
why this can be plausible let's take
one example let's take the normal random
variable
then the marginal is also normal
and this estimate is obviously true
unfortunately it's pretty easy to come
up with a counter example
even if you assume the expectation is
zero
uh the variance is uh one
and first decay even boundedness you
just take the
uh the uh
density one on the small interval
and add to delta functions of course
delta function doesn't have an
uh density but this is an artificial
obstacle you smoothen it
and then the even the density at
zero will be dependent
on the ambient dimension
even if you consider a
a hyperplane
so if we cannot do this
for any density with light
tails maybe we can do it for uh for some
more general density than
just the normal one
and then the question was whether
you can do it for the uniform density
and i consider uniform density of
negative one half on negative one half
one half just to have
the density one and not to carry it
through the
the whole talk
uh it took some time
to figure out what uh what's going on
uh with this question and after it
was figured out unfortunately this
statistician didn't you know can
come back to me so i lost the original
source of this question but the question
turned out to be
quite interesting on its own
and if we consider uniform density on
negative 1 1 we have we can reformulate
it geometrically
the product density is the uniform
density of the cube of the unit volume
and then the marginal density is just
the volume
of the section so we can reformulate it
saying that whether it's true that
the volume of any section of the cube
[Music]
at the distance at most one half from
the origin
can be bounded below
and since this is about sections of the
cube
there is a large body of research on the
question
fortunately for us first
everything is known about the central
sections
not only the precise estimates but
the precise position of the minimal
and maximal section so for the minimal
section
their position is a coordinate subspace
and of course in this case the section
is a cube so the volume is at least
one the maximal section was explicitly
described by
ball and
the volume is at most 2 to the d over 2
and this is exact and the maximal
section is not a diagonal
much less is known for nonsense
it's not always exact sorry
it's not the exact form it's exactly
bigger than
yes n over two yes
actually less than not bigger
but less uh it depends on
whether there is a dimension of e right
okay okay okay much less is known
for uh the non-central section and
actually
the results appeared only a few years
ago
first uh the maximal hyperplane section
was
determined by moody stone zakonsvavich
a couple of years ago but in the case
where the shift has a large norm
the meaning of this large norm is that
uh the section and the subspace is a
hyperplane
the section by this hyperplane
leaves only one vertex of the cube
in one half space and the rest of the
cube is
in the other half space so it is easier
to analyze
and very recently caldopski and konig
obtained an upper estimate for the
hyperplane sections
and one take from this comparison of
central and non-central results
is that the position of the maximal
section
would depend on the distance for the
very large distance
it is diagonal for the central one it is
not so the problem
uh what was going on at the distance one
half
may be more difficult and
actually it is because it's extremely
sensitive because
of this one-half
let's see if i take uh the vector
in the coordinate direction with a
normal less than one-half
the section will be of course a volume
one
but if i take it with the
shift of norm greater than one half it
misses the
cube entirely and the
the volume as zero and if i keep it one
half but rotate it slightly
it is about one half so it doesn't
even if you you stay below one half it
is not continuous
okay so this is our
uh question and let me pass to the
results first
for the general dimension
uh we have this
result it is true that
the volume of the section or the
marginal is bounded by a quantity
independent of the ambient
dimension n
we haven't
wrote we haven't written this function
fine but if you trace the proof that
dependence is pretty bad
it's exponential
in polyd
i'll discuss later the question whether
one can do
anything better but at least it is a
function of d
only so
in a nutshell the proof has two main
main ingredients first
it's a kind of a
soccer type we repeatedly pass
between the probabilistic and geometric
version of the problem until it gets
almost real and
so the second main ingredient
is that we have different shifts
and we are going to treat them
differently
we will consider the vectors which are
compressible and incompressible
the compressible vectors are vectors
with a few large coordinates and the
norm is
concentrated on these large coordinates
vector closed to the low dimensional
subspace
and the incompressible vectors are the
rest
this idea was introduced about 15 years
ago in a random matrix context
and then it became a standard tool where
here the question has nothing to do with
random matrices
nevertheless this decomposition pops up
so let's before we treat even uh
compressible vectors
let's treat the vectors
which are very compressible namely
vectors with a very large
coordinate
so our goal is obtaining the
uh the probability density lower bound
for the probability density and it is
possible to obtain it
uh let's consider the projection
where we on the subspace
and this projection forms
the composition of the identity
consider a partial case where
one of these vectors has
a huge norm the norm almost one
so the subspaces are the kernel of the
projection is almost orthogonal
to a coordinate axis
then because we have such a nice
expression
it's possible to use the characteristic
function and
especially manipulate these
characteristic functions
uh to reduce it to the to what ball did
but we need another condition
on the direction of the ship we don't
want to spoil this decomposition
and the shift is going to be parallel
to one of the projections of the
coordinates
axis namely to the to this large one
then just for algebraic reason the
calculations
go through so we got a discrete
collection of the of the directions and
shifts
in which our inequality is established
let's start from it
and let's try to use some stability
and indeed there is stability
and this is guaranteed by geometric
property
namely by log concavity
so what we can do we have we have to
keep this
condition that one of the projections
is very large
actually even reducing this epsilon of d
but we can move the vector
uh v slightly it's not
parallel to this direction but almost
parallel to it
we can move it a little in the
orthogonal direction
and then our bound will still hold
the reason for it i
consider the the density
as a function of t t is the shift
in the orthogonal direction and this
density being a marginal
uh the look concave density is not
concave
i know that if t is zero it's large
and long low concavity
precludes to a fast decay of this
density
so it it will remain
large in a small interval
okay so we got
this estimate for a
a small portion of this sphere
let's extend it and now i'm going to
switch to compressible vectors
before it uh
combining this i can
uh cover the part of the directions
where the l infinity norm is
almost one remember v is a unit vector
so they'll do normal is one so it's
almost coordinate directions
now let's switch to compressible vectors
what happens for them first of
all uh compressible vectors
carry non-negligible mass on
on small coordinates so i take delta
being a small number and consider the
set of small coordinates
and these coordinates carry a
non-negligible mass
then i can drop all large coordinates
and use a barrier at the berry as an
inequality
and it would yield that this probability
is large
the problem is that this is uh
the probability of a half space it has
nothing to do
with the density and to connect it with
the density we again will use geometry
and again
use log concavity
so let's consider
the set uh
the upper level set
of the marginal density
since it's well concave this is a
complex and symmetric
set and then
uh i my point
one half v lies on its boundary
i take a supporting hyperplane
and i draw a normal
to this hyperplane inside this is the
subspace input
here u is a unit vector and
is the scaling and just from the picture
we see that
is doesn't exceed one half
this this is absolute trivial uh the
norm of
uh one half v is one half
but this trivial observation will be
helpful later
okay so this is the picture and then it
turns out that you can relate the
density
of the marginal at the point one half
b and the
uh the measure the probability of uh
the half space above
this supporting hyperplane
this is also due to the log
concavity of the marginal density
and process of it unfortunately we gain
the power we have d
and this power is the major source of
uh the loss of precision
okay so what did we gain first of all
we reduce bounding density
to bounding probability
second our uh subspace
had a general code dimension here we are
in the situation of the code i mentioned
one this is the
just the inner product and this is what
we are going to uh
to bound below as soon as i have this
i can combine it with variation
and be done with incompressible vectors
great so what remains is compressible
vectors
let's consider compressible vectors and
those are vectors
for which the small coordinates
carry only a small norm
and we can consider as we saw
before we can consider only
the inner product
so we decompose this inner product into
the
small and large coordinates
and when we apply barriers
we dropped the large coordinates and
worked
only with the small ones here i'm going
to do the opposite
thing i drop the small coordinates and
work with the large ones actually we can
drop
any set of correlates
okay and
so we reduced our problem
to the same one but
instead of the vector u we consider the
vector w
which is uh which contains only
large coordinates and for convenience
i divided i normalized our
inequality by the norm of w so it looks
very much
like what we need we did some
translations and returned more or less
to the original problem
what did we get the game
is in the dimension
the set of large coordinates
cannot be too large it
has at most d to the negative two
elements
delta to the negative two elements and
delta e is dependent only on
the dimension d and is independent of
n and now since i am
looking for the estimate which is
dependent of d
uh i will define with the
estimate which depends on the m bin
dimension
by the way this is this argument can be
carried over
without any compressible and
incompressible part
we can't drop all coordinates except
a few and rewrite the problem like this
so why did i uh i
told the previous why did i tell the
previous story the reason is
in this normalization we remember that
torque was less than one half
this was a triality but now i normalized
it
and do over the norm of this vector
can be uh greater than one half
and if the shift is greater than one
half we can miss the cube entirely this
will be zero
so we have to make sure that this
doesn't happen let's analyze when it
happens okay
our vector is compressible which means
that
the small coordinates carry only
a very small mass which means that the
vector w has norm almost
one two is less than one half
and tau divided by norm of w
is greater than one half when can it
happen
first of all it can uh it can be only
slightly greater than one half
and if it is slightly greater than one
half
and we miss the cube
it means that we are our vector
is close to one of the coordinate
directions
its l infinity norm is large
and this allows us to finish
uh the proof
so if the section doesn't uh miss the
kill
obtaining a dimension dependent estimate
is not
a big deal this is basically elementary
convex geometry
and if the the storm is large
this case has been already taken care of
at the very beginning
and then summing up we
finish the proof if we are not
going after the precise
any questions at this point um
so i was wondering do you think that go
enough to precise bound would be
possible
if you do a more precise decomposition
and what comes to mind is actually
i think your paper is bosak or just
maybe
in this case you would need to like
split compressible and compressible by
the levels of delta from delta being one
over m
you know this is not about the final
decomposition
there is a weak point in this argument
and the weak point is here
as soon as you uh you try to pass from
density to probability you incur
a big loss
okay
so now let's consider one
partial case one-dimensional marginals
or hyperplane sections and
let's go after a
reasonable bound not just
any bound and here we can
provide some numerical bound
this 1 17
is by no means precise
but this is not part of the optimal
thing actually
it's only 5.2
times smaller than
the possible optimal bound
and this 5.2 is obtained by comparison
with the diagonal subspace and then a
hyperplane orthogonal to the diagonal
vector and the proof here has nothing to
do with the previous
one there will work
with translations between probability
and geometry
here it's uh analysis
and we start with uh the formula
for the volume of the hyperplane section
hermann founded in a
1913 paper of poliah
but it it's possible that someone
found it even earlier
this is just uh using fourier transform
and for inversion formula
and this is of course a highly
oscillating integral
it didn't prevent a ball from obtaining
his result
but this cosine messes the things up
significantly
and we know it's highly unstable if i
put here
as a coefficient close to one it changes
everything
so the first aim would be to write a
different formula for it
which is stable which avoids oscillating
integrals
and this is possible
we can uh represent the volume
as the integral of a positive quantity
so let's consider independent
identically distributed vectors
on the two-dimensional sphere in r3
and then the shifted section
will be the integral of the reciprocal
of the norm
of the linear combination of these
vectors with coefficients which are
coordinates of
a and the integral is taken over the set
where this norm is at least one
it's it doesn't look very much connected
to the
polya's formula but actually it is the
same
and the proof is a very easy exercise in
free analysis
so the first observation and this
is uh one of the first exercises in
the usual convicts germany records that
if you take a unit vector
on s2 take its one dimensional
marginal it's a unit
uniform distribution on the interval
which allows us to
rewrite this sync
function as
a fourier transform of the inner product
of u
against any
unit vector we can do it for a and for
each same function
and so there
uh we'll get that uh this product of c
since it is the
integral of these exponents
then we sum up the the product of the
exponents
is the exponent of the sum and then we
apply the same
equalities the second time translating
this
exponent into the same function
so now i have here sorry i have here
a sink function but this is a one sync
function
not the product of sync functions
and then we complete
polya's formula integrate
by parts use fubini and simple counter
integration and we are done
when i asked a stupid question but
didn't polio derive his
formula from your lemma and the lamb
would derive geometrically like
this would be the nature of logic here
yeah
uh i didn't read the paper of polia but
i suggest i
i believe it was done the simpler way
using the fourier inversion formula
directly
it's uh sure it's just that the number
seems like the geometric
kind of basis for it but maybe i'm
completely wrong so anyway so sorry
uh so almost i said fubini
is not a cannot be applied here because
we have s in the denominator the
function is
not l1
but we can we still can justify
switching the integrals
although this requires some work
okay so we have this formula
and we have done below this
integral first let me rewrite it
by uh just
uh standard integration
like this and we have the integral
of the probability that it's between one
and something large
let's look at this quantity u is uh
uniformly distributed on the sphere
it's a sub gaussian vector
of the linear combination would be
subgaussian
its norm decays quickly
and so uh the action
occurs when this norm is relatively
small
and when it is relatively small
we can bound it essentially we can bound
it below by
the probability that
this norm is at least one
okay let's simplify it even more
if it is uh at least one i can square
it for free and then i can develop the
square
cancel one which is the equilibrium norm
of
a and i'm left
with this quadratic form
i have to estimate the probability that
this quadratic form
is not negative at this moment we can
forget about the original problem
we have a quadratic form
of some vectors
and we want to estimate the probability
that
it is positive
so what do we know about this form
trivially since it
it lacks the diagonal the expectation is
zero but this random variable is not
symmetric
so we have a random variable with
expectation
zero and we want to estimate the
probability that it is positive positive
and nice exercise on it uh
it should be known but
surprisingly not very much is known
about it
the only reference we know was given to
us by sasha kwapin it's
the paper of there are addressing
exactly this problem
but our best mate god is to lose
we have to work harder so how can we do
it
let's uh take
the expectation of the positive part of
why
i can for free multiply
by the indicator of the positive
semi-axis of y and then
i can estimate it using any bonnet space
norm i want
and let's take orlish norms
i estimated by the norm of y in the
original space
and the dual norm
and this dual norm of the indicator
is obviously connected to the
probability
and we can use it to estimate the
probability
from below and the faster
the early function l grows the better
this estimate would be
it cannot grow faster than exponential
because uh then y plus
our y class will not be in this
orange space but it can be exponential
so we choose l of exponential type
the most natural choice would be psi 1
but psi 1 is
not going to work well here and we
consider
another exponential type voltage
function
mainly but mainly the same as
psi one so
to bound this norm of indicator from
below
we have to bound the expectation of y
plus below
and the oralist norm of white loss
above and the main part in it
is bounding the exponential
moment above the first part is easy
we know how to do it since the
expectation
of y is zero
the expectation of y plus is just one
half expectation of the absolute value
of y
and bounding the expectation of absolute
value below is a piece of cake
where it's done for example and in
proof of the hinge and inequality if you
know the second and the fourth moment
you can do it and the second and the
fourth moment can be calculated
explicitly
the problem is what to do with the
exponential moment
there is uh
okay all large deviation theory is
devoted to bounding exponential moments
but here we have this plus which
messes the things up and we want to get
rid of it
so let's get rid of it and of course
and we can estimate it with the usual
moments
and this would not be a big deal this is
a triviality
the exponential actual of lambda y plus
is point wise less than
the sum this is a triviality and this is
not very helpful
however we have an additional condition
that the expectation of y is zero
and we can get some mileage and
actually a lot of mileage we can get a
coefficient one-fourth
in the second exponential moment
actually if this uh
second exponential moment is too large
we can do even better
but we do not need it in our proof
because the lambda we use doesn't
satisfy this condition
but this one-fourth is going to be
important
okay so instead of this
y plus we have a usual laplace transform
what can be better than that
and now we have to bound the laplace
transform
so uh now
it's time to recall what our y
is otherwise we don't have
much chance to bound it this is a
quadratic form
use our sub gaussian random vectors
if they their coordinates were
independent we could use handsome right
actually with some effort handsome right
can be carried over here as well
but it turns out that it is
it also incurs losses we and if we want
to get
a relatively tight estimate
we would like to do better than handsome
right
and the the way to improve it
it's to get inside a relative
laplace transform proof of hands and
write inequality
and inside this proof use the spectral
structure
of this quadratic form it turns out
that it can be split and the main
part will have one positive
eigenvalue the rest will be negative
and this can be used in the laplace
transform estimate
and this will lead to 1 17.
so as i promised
i finished a little early and
since i'm the last speaker let me
thank the organizers for this wonderful
workshop
yeah thanks mark uh
yeah thanks for a very intriguing result
um
so first of all uh yeah are there any
questions
yes uh just a
just a couple let me narrow down to a
couple so
first of all uh does your result implies
that if you take any decreasing
um uh distribution that's supported on
the cube
and take id copies automatically
you get the bound for that as well
and not any decreasing um
even not on the queue
actually it can be extended
to a larger class of random variables
and
uh probably you can guess which class
exactly the
this uh this notion pops up
every second line into in the first
proof
the only part of the proof which is
which did require the exact
union uniform density was the fourier
transform argument the characteristic
functions argument
at the very beginning of the proof
but this can be done separately and this
can be extended to lock concave measures
of course it can i mean
[Music]
it's not so directly uh of course but it
can
can you state the version for log
concave measures
uh for any uh
[Music]
okay uh let me
go to the very beginning
no that's not this
okay
so suppose
that x i's are
[Music]
all concaves
on r and
the variance is bound zero expectation
variance
bounded above and the density
is bounded below on the interval
negative a
a then
the density is bounded below that is if
the marginal is bounded below
ah if the shift doesn't exceed and
and i was i was wondering mark also
about the converse like
upper estimate but if you from below
requires that the shift is big enough do
you see what i mean
is concentration
not necessarily big like suppose you
know that the shift is
well actually peak picture shift now for
this specific shift
what is the maximum density
maximum hyperplane section
if the shift is zero suppose if it's a
cube
and if it's a hyperplane section if the
upper estimate was obtained
by uh kernig and koldovsky
it is tight if the shift is zero then it
coincides with ball
it's it's not known whether it's tight
for non-zero shifts
but they have some decrease in yes yes
any other questions
can you return to this inequality by
laplace transform
of the y plus uh i didn't realize
why it was important to get a
coefficient smaller than one
why because
yeah because
these exponential moments both of them
grow
pretty fast and we are after a
relatively tight estimate
and why does it help to get to have his
smaller coefficient okay
uh smaller coefficient means that
extreme a smaller coefficient means that
i can
before it i can introduce
the earliest function l with large
lambda
and this norm will be still small
good seems reasonable
okay uh it seems there are no more
questions so uh
yeah thanks to all the speakers again
thanks to the participants for sticking
around
and enjoy the weekend
thanks again